[Musik]
es ist doch wunderbar dass wir unsere
lieblings literatur als hörbücher durch
die gegend tragen können immer dann wenn
es danach ist verabschieden wir uns ein
wenig von der welt sie ist ja nicht
immer schön diese welt bücher dagegen
sind was sie sind zu hause können wir
abwaschen oder hemden bügeln und dabei
hören wir können karotten schnippeln
dösen oder träumen und hören einfach
weiter in der heutigen folge des faz
bücher podcast möchte ich über das
vorlesen und hören von literatur
sprechen und zwar mit einem der menschen
die am besten dauer bescheid wissen
frank arnold eine der bekanntesten
stimmen des audio markt daneben möchte
ich dank abstatten nämlich an vier oder
michael wittstock ski den großen
russischen erzähler der ziemlich genau
vor 200 jahren geboren wurde und der
wieder und wieder neu übersetzt wird
offenbar hat er uns noch viel zu sagen
heute ist sonntag der siebte november
ich bin paul ingendaay und ich freue
mich dass sie dabei sind
[Musik]
jeder von uns hat eine persönliche lese
geschichte die mit dem täglichen
kleinigkeiten mit allen entwicklungen
wechselfällen und peinlichkeiten des
lebens verbunden ist meine eigene lese
geschichte begann im internat das in den
ersten jahren ein sehr dunkler ort für
mich war mit einer sehr strengen ordnung
den kirchgängern dem gebet und der
gewissenserforschung bücher boten mir in
dieser zeit die einzige
fluchtmöglichkeit weshalb meine
dankbarkeit ziemlich genau der eines
schiffbrüchigen gegenüber seinem floß
entspricht bücher haben mich weg
getragen von den gefahren des lebens
bücher haben verhindert dass sich
unterging ich erinnere mich noch an den
ersten abend natürlich ein sonntag an
dem 14 jährigen jungen in alphabetischer
reihenfolge auf die schlafsäle verteilt
wurden und uns dort um 20.15 nach dem
abendgebet abzulegen hatten in zwei
reihen zu je fünf kindern in der ecke
begann es mit h dann kam
jk noch heute weiß ich alle zehn namen
und besonders genau erinnere ich mich
darin welches buch ich las als die
strenge ordensschwester um punkt 21 uhr
hereinkam und das licht löschte das war
unser tag gewesen noch nicht einmal ein
guter tag denn viele von uns waren
verwirrt an diesen neuen fremden ort der
uns gleich in eine ordnung presste und
effizient verwaltet und jetzt war dieser
erste tag eben zu ende
ich las also astrid lindgren
meisterdetektiv kalle blomkvist gelber
umschlag darauf ein junge mit einer lupe
in der hand aber da wurde schon das
verdammte licht ausgeknipst und wir
mussten schlafen
jahre später es ging mir besser aber die
internats welt war noch immer kein
einladender ort entdeckte ich durch ein
freund den unsterblichen das csg und
später fand ich auch heraus dass die
übersetzungen die wir lasen aus dem jahr
1910 stammten aber
der ältliche stil erklärt er noch nicht
dass fremde andere dass mir industries
sprache entgegentrat es erklärte nicht
sein rasen des fiebrige sankt petersburg
die verrückten dialoge die endlose
selbstbefragung seiner figuren die
vielen kranken und elenden oder die
kinder und die pferde
in diesen monaten lasse ich zuallererst
seine kleinen romane darunter auch der
doppelgänger über einen beamten namens
golden king in rundheraus lächerliche
figur und meine erinnerung hat vor allem
einen eindruck aufbewahrt wie sehr ein
mensch sich von sich selbst entfernen
kann um anerkennung ringt sich blamiert
meistens vor publikum
und die verlorenen teile seines selbst
einfach nicht zusammengebaut kriegt die
sprache in der diese geschichte eines
sankt petersburger beamten erzählt wurde
habe ich mit 14 jahren natürlich einfach
geschluckt
so sonderbar sie anfangs auf mich wirkt
ich lasse mich doch schnell in sie ein
und bald empfand ich sie für diese
groteske wirklichkeit weil es völlig
natürlich und angemessen bücher heißt
das erschaffen sich den modus indem sie
gelesen werden wollen bücher erschaffen
sich ihre leser und ganz sicher war die
düstere niederrheinische welt um mich
herum ein mitgrund warum ich instinktiv
nach dem stärksten stoff griff den das
neunzehnte jahrhundert überhaupt
anzubieten hat
geboren 1821
gestorben 1881 das waren die ersten
literatur daten die ich mir als
jugendliche überhaupt ein prägte und
jahrelang massig alle anderen
lebensdaten die mir unterkamen an denen
das zu jetzt kies dem helden meiner
jugend
nominell der zwei jahre früher als toski
geboren
zehn jahre später gestorben tolstoi
wurden 29 jahre älter als der ossietzky
starb 1910
elend in einer einsamen bahn station auf
der flucht vor seinem eigenen leben
1910 starb übrigens auch mark twain und
eigentlich wäre das eine schöne
doppelbiografie wie der russe tolstoi
und der amerikaner mark twain zwei der
berühmtesten schriftsteller ihrer zeit
zur literarischen giganten ihrer länder
wurden
ihre mit wird dabei mit ihren komischen
manchmal auch nervtötenden alters
schulen in atem hielten klar und im
selben jahr 1910 starben natürlich unter
ziemlich verschiedenen umständen
vielleicht sollte einer von ihnen die
gerade zu hören dieses buch schreiben
aber
jetzt zu dem was uns heute im faz bücher
podcast besonders beschäftigt der
literatur die man nicht liest sondern
hört und den stimmen denen man sich
dabei an vertraut
[Musik]
ich freue mich wahnsinnig dass ich jetzt
frank arnold vor mir sitzen habe dessen
fan ich bin wenn ich wurde als ich
wieder ein tauchte in hörbücher und das
war tatsächlich in der pandemie nach
einer ersten heißen phase vor jahren kam
ich zurück zu hörbüchern und habe das
kann ich ja ruhig jetzt als fan bekennen
ihre
schlafwandler gehört die ich noch nicht
als buch hatte und da habe ich
weitergemacht und jetzt würde ich ganz
gerne hören von ihnen herr not was
bedeuten die schlafen da ein wichtiges
historisches buch ein bestseller in
seiner zeit und einen enormen ja einen
debatten freudiges buch weil es ja auch
weiter geht wie sehen wir den ersten
weltkrieg und arbeiter was hat für sie
bedeutet ja eigentlich das passiert
schon gesagt haben also man lernt aus
dem buch
eindeutigkeiten in zukunft zu vermeiden
man sieht wie so oft dass dinge gerade
historische dinge viel komplexer sind
als man geglaubt hat und
dieser auto hat so viel investiert in
die recherche in die archiv arbeit dass
ich das buch auch sehr überzeugend fand
interessant ist dass die metapher vom
schlafwandler die dem buch den titel
gibt ja sehr spät kommt erst war das
eigentlich beschreibt warum dass
schlafwandler sind das buch ist ja auch
kritisch aufgenommen worden von einigen
leuten weil es so ein bisschen als ohne
auch der deutschen position also
erreicht aufgefasst wird was ich
überhaupt nicht findet das buch wird
allen seiten in gewisser weise gerecht
aufzeigen dass keine seite irgendeiner
weise frei von schuld in die
verstrickungen dieses unglaublichen
konfliktes ist und das zweite was mich
sehr interessiert und fasziniert hat ich
habe schon meine revue für das
deutschlandradio gemacht zum neunzigsten
geburtstag eine anführungszeichen des
ersten weltkriegs habe ich eine radio
review inszeniert die wir zeughaus
gemacht haben und dann das gesendet
sondern also live aufgenommen vor
publikum da haben wir uns schon sehr mit
dem ersten weltkrieg beschäftigt und als
dann das buch kam
habe ich gedacht das ist noch mal eine
vertiefung also für mich war das ein
großer gewinn ist mittlerweile übrigens
auch die beiden nächsten bücher von
clark auch schon aufgenommen nämlich den
wilhelm in zweiter reihe ich bin
natürlich sofort dahin gegangen ich
hätte nie eine ich auch nicht sollte da
muss ich sagen bin ich nicht ganz so
glücklich gewesen weil meine
einschätzung von wilden zeiten
eigentlich etwas negativer ja ja und
dann hat er noch ein buch über macht
geschrieben was auch interessant ist
dass verschiedene epochen parallel setzt
so aber ein sehr interessanter ist ich
finde es wunderbar dass sie natürlich
durch ihre arbeit hinein gestoßen werden
auch in diese intensive beschäftigung
mit den autoren deren bücher sie lesen
und ich wollte eigentlich heute auch
anfangen nicht nur mit historischen und
auch mit klassischen ich bin nämlich von
ihrem
schlafwandler wofür christopher clark
weitergegangen zu wieder in dem zweiten
war auch verblüfft wie milde er
betrachtet wird von clark und bin dann
ich habe den katalog so durchgeschaut
und hab gesehen auf einmal er frank
arnold hat auch rot und schwarz gemacht
das buch habe ich 30 jahre nicht gelesen
das probiere ich mal und war auch da
verblüfft wie eine doch eher alte
übersetzung denn die sind lizenzfrei
genauer zwischen
wirkt wenn man sie gut liest was
empfinden sie wenn sie die alten texte
in shows geworfen kriegen und dann das
draus machen passieren großes glück
ganz einfach weil man die chance hat
sich mit texten zu beschäftigen von
berufswegen und davon irgendwann auch
teilweise die miete bezahlen kann was ja
auch nicht ganz unwichtig ist und das
ist ein reines glück das ist ein großes
privileg und zu sich das überhaupt meine
arbeit also insofern dann kommt es
darauf an was man liest es
sind eben auch ich hatte ja so ein
bisschen das privileg auch wirklich alte
text zu lesen es gibt einen regisseur da
hat man gesagt du bist ideal für die
texte des achtzehnten jahrhunderts
das wäre mir ein bisschen zu wenig aber
ich verstehe was er meinte weil diese
texte das ist mir vollkommen organisch
das ist eigentlich nie eine sprache wo
ich den kopf ist es kompliziert sondern
ich habe angst davor gelesen so die
reise um die welt von forst ich finde
forster in der ganz großen posten der
deutschen literatur wenn ich ja nicht
der einzige goethe war der erste der das
gesagt hat und das ist einfach eine
unglaubliche bereicherung wenn man das
machen kann man merkt dann natürlich
auch wie viel in der sprache heute
verloren gegangen ist und man kann das
bewahren und in dem man es dann spricht
und versucht eine haltung dazu zu finden
das ist sehr unterschiedlich konnte auf
den text an ich hatte auch das gefühl
als ich ihren star dahl gehört habe und
ihren dossiers gehört habe dass sie sich
im ins wohlfühlen im 19 jahrhundert
überhaupt mit älteren texten und dann
glaube ich kommt nur auf die
sprachkultur an die dazu gehöre zum
leben zu bringen ist ich würde ganz gern
ein paar ganz profane fragen stellen die
nicht interessieren und vielleicht auch
viele die gerne hörbücher hören wie
lange können sie am tag
wenn sie ins studio gehen arbeiten an
lesen eines textes also jetzt müssen
alle weghören weil sonst kriege ich
ärger mit kollegen ist schon öfter
gehört auch mit in dem western ich habe
auch schon zehn stunden aufgenommen ich
habe es schon 200 seiten am tag
aufgenommen einmal sogar 230 das war ein
ganz schlechtes buch was ich sehr gut
vorbereitet über die später nehmen sie
nichts von
den
schlechten also das kommt darauf an aber
ich habe sagen wir mal so ein schnitt
wenn ich ins studio gehe denke ich
zwischen 120 und 180 seiten am tag
nämlich auf und das kommt natürlich
jetzt darauf an wie komplexen buch ist
also wenn ein buch auch ein formal und
von den satzstrukturen sehr komplex ist
dann dauert das natürlich viel länger
das heißt man ist lange im studio aber
schafften nicht so viel darf ich kurz
fragen wenn sie sagen es dauert länger
dass sie mal gelegentlich stolpern in
den see nicht nur gelegentlich ich bin
zum beispiel jemand der sich selbst
nicht der tonmeister sondern ich
unterbreche mich selbst oft und habe
früher die marotte und das kann man das
nicht nennen gehabt zu sagen für einen
satz den ich auf einer seite habe ich
zwei ganze sätze zurück und macht dialog
und zum zu diesem satz wieder zu kommen
irgendwann habe ich das richtige
reduziert genau es gibt ja diese regel
das kennen sie man geht ein bisschen
zurück ein zwei sätze und dann kann der
gut schneiden da tun was du für mich ist
extrem wichtig wie der gestus davor ist
um dann den satz bei der der verunglückt
ist sozusagen den gut zu sprechen
brauche ich das davor noch mal für mich
leute die sagen hier macht aufs wort und
dann mit dem adjektiv geht's weiter erst
wenn ich das sehe ich auch sofort ein
weil sie ja tatsächlich den flow
brauchen auch und vor allem wenn man
auch figuren versucht zu erfinden da ist
es ja so man ist in einer figuren da
muss man ja in der figuren wie bleiben
das geht besser wenn man zurück geht
jetzt weiter zum technischen
handwerklichen auf die gefahr dass jedes
alles schon mal jemandem erzählt haben
wie lange er so lange am stück das
hatten wir aber wie fliegen sie sich
über den tag dann sie trinken genug
nehme ich an die brauchen wir nicht nein
sie machen ja vor keine risky nacht ein
vielleicht wirklich stimmt also ich
mache zum beispiel ich komme ja richtig
klassisch auch auf dem einsatz seminar
schauspiel studiert und wir haben in der
zeit ich hab dir zwischen 76 und 80 das
war die zeit wo wir sehr viel werbung
gemacht haben wir haben ein kilo gemacht
wir haben also diese neuen bioenergetik
wir haben sehr viele arten gemacht wir
haben sehr viel stimme gemacht wir haben
gesungen ich bin ja ein sänger sohn also
mein vater sagen morgens stunden also
sich einzusingen für den abend und das
habe ich eigentlich
weiter geflogen so und ich mache am tag
fast immer je älter ich werde
strenger eine halbe bis 45 minuten halbe
stunde für man so eine übung das ist so
ein kanon ausdehnungen aus dings weniger
stimmen sollen klimadaten alles mögliche
liegen stehen so und das ist ich brauche
das weil wenn eine sache die sehr
anstrengend ist das denkt man oft nicht
sprechen ist eine ganz komplexe
muskelarbeit hat mir eine
physiotherapeutin mal erklärt 30 bis 40
muskeln im nackenbereich den mice
bereich sind daran beteiligt und wenn
sie fünf sechs stunden in einer hohen
konzentration sprechen muss das
entspannt werden und das versuche ich
zum echten wenn ich das nicht mache
fehlt mir das richtig ich sollte das den
zuhörerinnen und zuhörern beschreiben
dass sie auch sehr entspannt vor mir
sitzen dass sie würde ich sagen
idealgewicht haben absolut clean
aussehen nein das ist eine hinreißende
konzentration auf die stimmen ja das im
verbund mit literatur sprechen also
wirklich durchdringung sonst können sie
es nicht transportieren
fand ich selber als neuer höher
süchtiger seit anderthalb jahren sehr
aufregend und ich habe nicht wirklich
immer wieder hinein versetzt in diese
spreche und hat besonders viel englische
und amerikanische schon mal wieder
gehört vor allen dingen männer ja weil
es gab ein paar wunderbare als stimmen
bei den frauen ich brauche er niedriger
also eher tiefe stimmen zum zuhören und
ich war dann verblüfft wie toll ich
immer wieder die neuen stimmen die ich
kennenlernte fand wieder ein anderer
charakter wieder ein anderer eine
verbindung zwischen dem der stimme und
dem dem material dem stoff jetzt würde
ich ganz gerne unbedingt haben wollen
dass sie in
anknüpfend an ihre großartige schuld und
sühne
version von toski einmal in die heute
heißt es ja verbrechen und strafe
übersetzt von swetlana geier und zwar
veröffentlicht bei egon ammann sagt 94
und heute in den fischer taschenbüchern
zu haben das ist der auftakt von
verbrechen und strafe von dostojewski
anfang juli es war außerordentlich heißt
trat gegen abend ein junger mann aus
einer kammer die er in der s klasse zur
untermiete bewohnte auf die straße
hinaus und ging langsam als wäre eher
unentschlossen auf die k brücke zu
glücklicherweise war ihm eine begegnung
mit seiner wirtin auf der treppe erspart
geblieben
seine kammer lag unmittelbar unter dem
dach eines hohen fünfstöckigen hauses
und glich eher einem schrank als einem
wohnraum seine wirtin bei der er diese
kammer samt mittagessen und aufwertung
gemietet hatte wohnte ein stockwerk
tiefer in einer separaten wohnung und
jedes mal wenn er das haus verließ kam
er zwangsläufig an ihrer küche vorbei
deren tür zum treppenhaus fast immer
sperrangelweit offen stand und jedes mal
wenn er vor über kam hat er der junge
mann eine peinigende und feige
empfindung schämte sich ihrer und
runzelte die stirn er war bei seiner
wirtin tief verschuldet und fürchtete
sich ihr zu begegnen
[Musik]
erst einmal tief durchatmen
nach so einer stelle von dostojewski der
herbst kommt da möchte ich ihnen ein
paar buch tipps geben vor allem im
zusammenhang mit unserem großen toski
aber auch einigen seiner kollegen
kürzlich etwa ist erschien der
doppelgänger erinnern sie sich das buch
das ich mit vierzehn gelesen habe diese
neue ausgabe erschien im galiani verlag
gut 300 seiten stark 24 euro und was ist
hier an das besondere
alexander nitzberg hat nicht nur eine
neue übersetzung sondern eine
wiederherstellung der urfassung des
buches von 1846 geschaffen das war das
ja in den normalen erstmals in dem
russischen almanach vaterländische
annalen erscheint der roman wird
zerrissen als zu lang vor allem als
zügellos fantastisch empfunden und die
hoffnungen von früher als der junge
autor dostojewski den roman arme leute
geschrieben hatte diese hoffnung zerfall
zu staub aus dem gefeierten star wird
erst einmal ein auto ist der berühmteste
russische kritiker seiner zeit bei den
ski der zuvor ein enthusiastischer
förderer von dosky gewesen war der
schreibt
für das fantastische kann es in unserer
zeit nur einen ort geben das irrenhaus
nicht aber die literatur
man kann über diesen satz lange
nachdenken denn tatsächlich hat das die
jetzt geht ein gewisser weise beides
rehabilitiert die literatur wie das
irrenhaus auf beides schauen wir anders
seit er geschrieben hat und seinen
büchern
schauen wir anders aus das verrückte und
das exzentrische
das letzte argument könnte also lauten
die saat ossietzky blick damals nur als
romantisch empfunden gelegentlich auch
verspottet und verlacht er weist auf die
moderne des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
voraus und er lässt sich in diesem
kleinen buch auch an der sprache
erkennen und das ist das verdienst
dieser ausgabe
eine symphonie der redundanz nennt das
der übersetzer alexander nitzberg und
erklärt es sehr schön im nachwort
erzählt uns von einem exzessiven
gebrauch von wortwiederholungen
besonders das wort letztendlich er
erzählt von der magie eines menschen der
aus dem gefängnis seines kopfes nicht
herauskommt laut übersetzer eine
vollständige auslöschung ein
existenzielles herausfallen aus raum und
zeit er erwähnt die komik des frühjahrs
de ski die groteske statt der
sozialkritik die später so in mode kam
und bis zum ende des romans wissen da
eigentlich nicht ist der doppelgänger
den unser brava beamter sieht der real
oder nur eine einbildung vladimir
nabokovs übrigens im doppelgänger ein
meister charakters dies ist besonders
interessant war in der box eigentlich
als dass sie es die hasser in die
literaturgeschichte eingegangen ist aber
dieses kleine berg das lag ihm am herzen
seine schwimmverein über die großen
späten das csg romane müssen sie nicht
alle kennen interessant sind sie aber
sie sagen vielleicht mehr über nabokov
als über das csg ich nenne mal kurz die
hauptwerke von taste diese fünf großen
romane ohne die man als fan eigentlich
nicht sein kann
schuld und sühne oder auch verbrechen
und strafe der idiot die dämonen oder
auch böse geister der jüngling oder auch
ein grüner junge und die brüder
karamasow
alle von denen können die reichen
mehrfachen lesen am wenigsten häufig
müssen sie den jüngling lesen es ist von
den fünf in der schwächste am häufigsten
habe ich gelesen schuld und sühne oder
auch verbrechen und strafe das buch von
dem wir vorhin den anfang gehört haben
dies ist ein irres schnelles buch eine
kriminalgeschichte ein packender roman
und auch wenn er einen lustigen letzten
satz hat höre ich immer wieder zu diesem
buch zurück
[Musik]
eine der interessanten dinge an frank
arnold ist dass er seinen neigungen
nachgehen kann nicht nur was klassiker
angeht sondern auch was projekte
literarische texte angeht die ihm am
herzen liegen
zuvor
bevor da eintauchen möchte ich ein paar
zahlen auspacken und sie liebes publikum
damit bewerfen ich finde diese zahlen
unglaublich
innerhalb der letzten vier jahre
hat sich die zahl der hörbuch liebhaber
nutzer nutzerinnen und der podcasthörer
sehr deutlich gesteigert und das lässt
sich also an diversen dingen ablesen
einmal die regelmäßigkeit des zu
schalten oder einschalten oder auflegen
es dann natürlich die die endgeräte die
wir benutzen fast immer tendenziell das
smartphone heute vor vier jahren waren
es noch 42 prozent cd die ist also auf
fast halbiert inzwischen
und es sind inzwischen 74 prozent
smartphones und tablets die benutzt
werden um literatur und podcast zu
genießen wenn man sie hören will statt
das material zu lesen das finde ich eine
technologischen schub
und ich nehme an frank arnold sie haben
auch erfahrung damit dass fans ihrer
bücher ihrer lesungen ihn auch irgendwie
zeigen wie sie das konsumieren wie läuft
das kommt da jemand mal auf sie zu und
sagt wie toll ich trage diese stimme mit
mir
ja das kommt wirklich ein netter weise
und unschöne weise man freut sich auch
darüber wie man das gefällt was man
macht nach lesung passiert das ganz oft
da gibt es ja dann oft ein büchertisch
da liegen dann die cds aus und dann
kommen ganz oft leute gemacht werden sie
auch was signiert haben finde ich dann
mache ich dann sie signieren zum
beispiel also denn die wollen dann
irgendwas was ich gelesen habe es ist
immer ein bisschen übertrieben aber
warum soll man denen den spaß verderben
aber die sind dann so dass sie sagen ja
also das habe ich gehörten das habe ich
gehört und was machen sie da und dann
gibt es leute die man sagen können sie
nicht mal das aufnehmen und dann muss
ich oft sagen ja es wäre ein schönes
projekte haben sie mir ein verlag sagen
der das macht dann machen wir das das
kommt schon vor manchmal das ist doch
eine klasse frage gab es denn bei den
hörer vorspeise den ja doch ihrem
publikum vorschläge die sie gerne
aufgenommen hätten aber für real halten
unrealistisch noch machbar gibt es
natürlich noch ein beispiel was das
spiel ist ganz einfach jetzt gerade ich
habe eine lesung gemacht
hermann sudermann reise nach tilsit
zweimal verfilmt hochinteressant einmal
von veit harlan und einmal von murnau
wer mir das erzählt hat war herr
silberberg der war nämlich bei dieser
lesung und hat ein bisschen mit gedreht
war der gleiche gemacht über so lehmann
gut so der mann ein autor den wir glaube
ich alle nicht mehr so wirklich auf dem
schirm haben literaturwissenschaftler
aber ein zeitgenosse von gerhart
hauptmann und ganz erfolgreich und so
weiter völlig vergessen heutzutage ganz
tolle erzählung altmeisterlich großartig
hatte ich überhaupt nicht und da kamen
dann die eine dame die da aus ostpreußen
gebürtig und die familie ja ja und das
möchte ich verschenken gibt es das nicht
können sie im grunde für sie ein lesen
dann schön verpacken und aussehen so
verdammt genannt das
haben wir doch bald in einer es gibt
natürlich und dann gibt es diese ganz
großen werke und manchmal kann man das
dann durchsetzen die ganz großen werke
also unternehmer
wollte man das ist paul ist hier lenin
weiter pole will der deutsche leser in
paul nennen genauso ist es er selber hat
darauf bestanden gesagt weil ich auch
gemacht ergänzt dusy musik aufteilung
aus heißt es oft rund um das heißt der
tanz zur musik der zeit ganz direkt
übersetzt und das haben wir
gemacht auch da habe ich auch sehr sagen
wir mal den vorschlag gemacht weil ich
habe das buch gelesen habe dass ein
einmal vorgestellt auch im literaturhaus
berlin also das ist ja eine edition über
jahre gegangen ist von einem wunderbaren
kleinen verlag elfenbein verlag in
berlin großartiger verleger auch mal
sagen muss man sagen weil gerade dieses
ding ja doch aus einer ganz anderen zeit
kommt und dafür muss man ein publikum
sich schon genau hat aber auch geklappt
hat und ich vom verlag hier einige
begeisterte rezensionen sagen and tears
der englische aus genau so ist es und
dann habe ich gesagt habe das erfährt
auch wunderbar was 500 figuren es
unglaublich vielstimmig und dann haben
wir das geschafft über eine stiftung mit
dem verlag chbeck lohn bedient das zu
produzieren und das haben wir über 3 ich
glaube ist das nicht herrlich dass so
einer sein und fast gleich ja und das
war natürlich und dieses buch ist
soll nicht irgendwie werben aber das
buch ist deshalb oder dieses zyklus so
großartig war also leute kennen proust
aber
nicht und das ist genauso gut nur wenn
morgen das mal gesagt ja das genauso
geführt was noch viel unterhaltsamer
aber stimmt auch nicht aber es ist ein
gang durch das jahrhundert es ist ein
großartiges werk was überhaupt nicht
veraltet ist was diesen englischen witz
hat diese leichtigkeit aber auch ganze
große tief ganz für kunstgeschichte ganz
dann wissen sie aber reiche so an ich
dachte als der praxis kam unter anderem
hört diese dieses große werk ja sich
hier eine welt beschworen die wir auch
mit sehr mit dem britischen verbinden ja
wo alle england dieb aber eigentlich
einsteigen kann und ich glaube sogar
dass diese welt einen gewissen schaden
genommen hat durch den dreck sie ja und
man kann sie da dann noch mal wirklich
noch mal so zu sagen nostalgisch und das
war es zum beispiel so ein projekt wo
das gelungen ist wo wir gesagt haben wir
finden und da haben wir die stiftung
gefunden dann haben wir das gemacht sehr
konzentriert da sind aber mehrere kräfte
zusammen gekommen dass ihr interesse da
ist vielleicht eine idee jeder verleger
ganz wunderbar übersetzer und so also
dass genau das kam so zusammen und
manchmal gelingt das muss man sehr froh
und das ist natürlich dann für sie das
bleibt immer in ihrem hirn was sie da
gemacht also der paul ist insofern auch
in meinem hirn wald wenn sie ein buch
haben was die post was in einen solches
spanne von zeit beschreibt dann stoßen
sie ja immer büchern die im zwanzigsten
jahrhundert spielen immer wieder
irgendwie dagegen dass das wiso bilder
bilder so kommt was anderes sehen sie
plötzlich in dem buch sind sie dann
gehen sie wieder zurück und sehen szenen
vorsicht die ausgelöst sind durch ein
anderes buchen die schön auch dass beide
großen werke pro ist und jetzt nennen
die zeit im titel führen also genau
darum geht genau darum geht wie ein
senkblei geht es sie haben vorhin für
uns dass sie es gelesen wir haben jetzt
ein bisschen über die sitte können die
trends die tendenzen des hörbuch marktes
gesprochen
unter den älteren texten die sie
besonders aufgewühlt haben beim lesen
also die erste frage mal sie lesen das
buch schon vorher mal durch oder können
sie gleich reinspringen machen sich
markierungen
technik immer die gleiche wenn ich weiß
dass sie ein buch lese dann lese ich das
buch erst mal entweder kenne ich es
schon lese ist neu dann lese ich es mit
dem manuskript und mache mir meine
zeichen so ich bin da relativ manisch
also ich wenn ich ein buch nicht mit
zeichen versehen hat man das skript dann
fällt mir das schwerer ist oder ohne
geld unterbrechen und sagen sie haben
vorhin netterweise die halbe seite des
csd den sie drauf haben den haben sie
ohne zeit habe ich habe zuhause gebe ich
zu diese seite auch angeschaut und da
hängt die prägen sich dann natürlich ist
es interessant wenn man es einmal
gemacht hat kommt man wahrscheinlich
auch ohne das zeichen aus aber wenn sie
sehr viel lesen sie wollen ja auch
vielleicht den zuhörern ein wenig einen
eindruck geben wie geht das wenn sie
dann wach sind und eine geschichte
erzählen wollen und nicht am text kleben
wollen das ist bei lesungen noch extrem
da wollen sie die leute auch mal
angucken oder was dann hilft es sehr
genau zu wissen geht einsatz zu ende
nach unten oder geht er weiter oder ist
es anfragen sonst kurz welches symbol
kleines zeichen fragezeichen ist ein
pfeil nach oben ersatz abschluss ist
eine 90 grad links nach unten
dann gibt es ein satz der weitergeht ist
weil viele fielen ebenso wie thomas mann
lesen dann eine apparative philipp viele
pfeile auch bei pol also es ist einfach
eine technik für mich kollegen dieses
überhaupt nicht machen es gibt andere
die das auch von denen die sie gerne und
es lustig weil den redaktionen von
fernseh und radio und so gab es ganze
hängen schon so so immer so auszüge was
ist denn das sieht ja aus wie sonne
fliegen auf dem mars gibt es jedes mal
sehen aber jeder hat seine karriere sich
jeder braucht wenn ich dran ist ja einen
kleinen einen kleinen ein haus wie eine
partitur sogar zu ihr bringen das war
wohl die schulen auch ein kurz erwähnen
weil es natürlich sie übersehen den text
sie haben das nur bei mails nicht
gemacht weil es meinen so sehr schön das
wiederum ist aus dem besitz meines
vaters gewesen von dem habe ich
übernommen aber ich war natürlich froh
dass wir das noch einmal hier hören mal
ganz kurz zu roman anfängen ich bin ja
ich sehe für mich dass ja absolut
fetisch geschichten dieser roman
anfängern der erste satz der so nenne
ich vielleicht sogar um die erste absatz
je nachdem und gerade diesen diesen
dostojewski einstieg immer wenn ich in
der buchhandlung wird in der sache wenn
ich das buch schuld und sühne oder böse
geister in der behandlung wie gehe ich
mal ans regal und lest die ersten sitze
ich weiß nicht ob sie das mal gehört
haben wir ob es ihnen aufgefallen ist
bei manchen romanen hat das gs die
schrecklichsten enden also die blödesten
roman ausgänge die wahrscheinlich je ein
großer autor denn ich glaube es ist hier
tatsächlich auch in schuld und sühne wo
er diesen unfassbaren den aber nicht zum
einzigen mal hier macht das unfassbar
grausam
blöde er wieder eigentlich hatte ich
zitiere den letzten satz wenn ich darf
das könnte das thema der neuen
geschichte werden aber unsere jetzige
geschichte ist zu ende und das ist
natürlich ein zeitungsschreiber der sein
geld verdienen mussten mit fortsetzung
nicht und er sagt dass wie bei den
serien oder er fliegt heute auch nach
der neunten folge der zwölften staffel
muss darauf hingewiesen werden dass ist
noch eine 30 sphinx auch inzwischen
richtig toll ich habe ich das gehört zu
in dieselbe liga von blödheiten über den
großen russen wie etwa ich gerne erwähne
für alle die es noch nicht gehört haben
dass tolstoi sein krieg und frieden
einmal ende gut alles gut
das war natürlich ein
es war nötig als shakespeare zitat
gedacht aber wenn man es im deutschen
sagt hätten wir da im regal 1000 für von
der zeiten ende gut alles gut stehen
würde uns mit grausen abwenden so aber
haben wir krieg und frieden
[Musik]
ich möchte ihnen doch noch ein paar
dinge mit geben für diesen dunklen
herbst und für den winter und weil das
ja auch weihnachten es gibt ein
interessantes phänomen dass die
russischen klassiker betrifft das hat in
der tat auf dem deutschen buchmarkt
stattgefunden besonders im hanser verlag
der sich große verdienste erworben hat
nämlich
übersetzerinnen haben die wichtigsten
klassiker der russischen literatur des
19 jahrhunderts neu übersetzt und das
ist wirklich noch nicht so lange her
begann eine in der welle
ist über uns rein geschwappt und hat uns
diese enormen bücher in neuen fassung
gebracht krieg und frieden
und auferstehung der dritte tolstois
roman von barbara conrad übersetzt sie
hat ebenfalls dass sie es aufzeichnungen
aus einem totenhaus neu übersetzt
rosemarie tietze sie hat tolstois anna
karenina übersetzt
wäre besitzt sie hat iwan gontscharow
oblomow übersetzt ebenfalls das etwas
kürzer buch eine gewöhnliche geschichte
und ursula keller das ist ein ganz
aktueller literatur tipp hat in man esse
verlag
25 euro
dossiers aufzeichnungen aus dem
untergrund neu übersetzt alle diese
ausgaben haben den großen vorteil dass
sie nicht nur anmerkungen enthalten
sondern jeweils nach worten sogar
philologische apparate zum teil und die
übersetzerinnen erklären und was das
besondere ist diese 19 jahrhundert
bücher
in unserer zeit neu zu übertragen das
hat man vorher so nicht gehabt da haben
sich die alten übersetzungen die ich gar
nicht stehen will über jahrzehnte
gehalten aber kein wort der erklärung
was es denn bedeutet hat diese texte ins
deutsche zu bringen und was ist für die
deutsche sprache heißt und was ist für
die russische bedeutet
es gibt ein gemeinplatz der übersetzungs
theorie der heißt ein bisschen man
müsste das widerständige das schroffe
das unkonventionelle auch ins deutsche
bringen das ist eine heikle sache denn
manchmal wollen verleger manchmal wollen
auch leser das schroffe und gebrochene
nicht so gerne lesen sie wollen er sich
in das buch legen wie ein bett und
dennoch hilft es mal dieser konzeption
ein wenig nachzudenken denn manche
dieser übersetzerinnen haben uns erklärt
dass die sprache der russischen
klassiker wenn die besondere ist und
hierzu möchte ich ihnen am allerliebsten
einsatz von maxim gorki über tolstoi
zitieren er wollte erklären was das
knorrige bei tolstoi sei nicht das
geordnete nicht das schöne und saubere
das korrekte
gorki also schreibt sie glauben es wäre
ihm leicht gefallen dieses knorrige er
konnte sehr gut schreiben er hat es bis
zu neunmal durchgestrichen und beim
zehnten mal endlich war es dann knorrig
die bücher die ich ihnen gerade genannt
habe werde ich auch in die show notes
tun damit sie nachschlagen können
überlegen ob diesmal mit einem dieser
klassiker probieren wollen und bald ist
ja in der tat weihnachten
[Musik]
frank erneut hat es nicht nur klassiker
über die wir vorher gesprochen haben
gemacht er hat bücher von rüdiger
safranski navid kermani jürgen kaube er
hat viele sachbücher viel fiction viele
romane gemacht
und eine sache an der ihm besonders
liegt ist die lyrik die doch ein kleines
publikum hat und die man vielleicht auch
vor publikum aufführen sollte arbeit
kann sie natürlich auch ins hörbuch
bringen frank anhalt ja also vorbei was
sie sagen völlig richtig ist die lyrik
liebt es wenn der andere anwesend ist
ich habe ja sehr viel fürs literatur
festival und verschiedene andere
festivals aber vor allem hier in berlin
gelesen und erinnere mich an die
wunderbarsten juli gaben die wir hatten
also mit großartigsten autoren den
letzten 20 jahren
was für eine magie dort herrschte oft
wenn 45 jähriger bei den patriots
nacheinander larsen und im publikum
saßen alle möglichen anderen lyriker und
würden zu wie zb dieser funde ja auch
schon tot und so und wenn man dann die
deutsche stimme sein durfte für diese
nicht deutsch schreibenden autoren war
das natürlich ganz wunderbar weil
einsatz dazu lyrik ist für mich so ein
bisschen die stunde der wahrheit das ist
so der boden wo wir herkommen das in der
musik bach da da da zeigt sich es da
erweist es sich was man gedanklich
stimmlich auch aber eben auch vor allem
bogen in der musik in der versicherung
als sprecher macht und ich habe als ich
das buch von safranski über hölderlin
follis hat er
dankenswerterweise sehr viel härter den
gedichte zitiert in dem buch weil er
wollte seinen lesern hörern die nahe
bringen und das war eine wunderbare
arbeit sehr anstrengend weil wir ich war
halt nicht zufrieden ich habe gesagt
noch mal noch mal der tonmeister ist
verzweifelt da habe ich kurz fragen sie
haben sicherlich die gedichte dann
eigens gemacht und getrennt vom haupt
die acht ja also als lyrische sozusagen
als lügner also genau als lyrische
einheit zwischen den
beschreibungstexte oder den
biografischen erläuterungen von sophie
wurden praktisch die die gedichte
hineinmanövriert in den text um den
menschen auch klar zu machen was ist das
dieser hölderlin und für mich ist das
immer noch ein wunderwerk der deutschen
sprache
und auch das schöne an der lyrik ist da
ist nichts zu wissen oder zu erklären
oder richtig oder falsch wenn sie in
pausa satz haben das auto ist rot dann
kann man sein kurz autos rotpunkt er
wird sein sagt dass fotos rot und da
gibt es strukturen die klar und
eindeutig sind mit lyrik
ist der raum ganz offen und jeder der
märz- so ist das beim hörder dem gedicht
hat das glaube ich nicht verstanden dass
das so nicht zu verständlich kann man
ihre stimme anhören welche tageszeit
herrscht ich musste daran denken dass
wir dachten sie lesen ein safranski buch
und die lyrischen ein rein linie ganze
gedichte sind eher zu
demonstrationszwecken er würde als
zeigen an der syrien in seinen text fügt
die haben sie ja getrennt aufgenommen
hört sich ihre stimme anders an im laufe
des tages nicht nur wegen der müdigkeit
auch wegen der regel frage ob ich gebe
zu dass das müssen sie aber andere
fragen aber dann haben sie eigentlich
war nein ich nehme das nicht ich merke
warum genau die militanz stimmen das
würde ich nicht sagen dass dazu macht
man das zu lange und wie ein sprecher
auf der schauspielschule immer sagte der
die die die stimmen lippen usw das sind
muskeln und muskeln werden trainiert und
wenn man viel spricht dann spricht man
auch viel wie ein sänger und sänger muss
üben das ist wie hochleistungssport wenn
sie hohe töne oder auch andere singen
wollen jetzt beim sprechen auch so das
heißt ermüdung ist wenn die stimme nicht
sitzt oder wenn das nicht in ordnung ist
dann gibt es probleme aber sonst nicht
also ermüdung kenne ich so nicht nur der
tonmeister wenn der dann sagt du ich
merke bestimmte sachen denn gedanklich
nicht mehr so gegriffen und dann höre
ich außer sie denken ja unter umständen
wenn sie das so tun wie es uns vor hin
erzählt haben sieben acht neun stunden
am stück in im universum hause natürlich
pause aber das sind die universum ist
habe das auch genau richtig das was sie
sagen das ist ein schönes stichwort mehr
hilft das sehr ich glaube auch dem buch
wenn man im universum verbleibt wenn ich
einen roman lesen und der über sich vier
wochen zieht mit das wort ist das
eigentlich ungut das geht aber es
gefällt mir nicht also hier sehen können
ja absolut
konzentration und dann auch vertiefung
und es lange ist nicht weil man stolz
ist dass man sechs stunden lesen kann
nein weil das nach sechs stunden die ist
wie eine wie eine an der spirale ist es
das geht einfach tiefer und man ist frei
ja ich gehe ja wie oft hatte ich noch
einen tonmeister einen produzenten den
sie sehen und der mit ja das ist ja so
ich mache dann ist es seit vier jahren
nicht mehr metrische sec wenn er selber
theaterregisseur gewesen lange jahre und
habe auch für radio gemacht und so was
ich bin mein strengster wirklich ich bin
also ich merke sofort ich unterbreche
mich wenn andere sagen wieso das war
doch primär technisch zwar nicht prima
aber ich habe 34 tonmeister mit denen
ich viele jahre jahrzehnte eine stunde
arbeit und wenn die nur mit dem augenlid
zwicken durch die schreibe sie dann
breche ich schon ab und mach es nochmal
die müssen gar nicht viel sagen da guckt
man sich noch an das ist übrigens auch
ein wunderbares geschenk weil man mit
diesen menschen so intensiv arbeitet und
das sind jetzt
ist der große regisseur sonst so leute
die einfach und gut hören und klug sind
das müssen sie schon seit aber die
einfach sondern die höheren den sechsten
sinn habe ja die profis und das braucht
man weil der mann braucht es unbedingt
ganz alleine könnte man das niemals man
braucht das gegenüber ein vorher als ich
anfing radio zu machen als ganz junger
schauspieler der sagte moment ja das
mikrofon aber du musst dir vorstellen du
sprichst in das ohr eines menschen
hatte ich frage vor hingestellt weil mir
das neulich eine sprecherin erzählte so
gar nicht langer zeit die sagte
gelegentlich wird sie auch allein
irgendwo eingesetzt also innenraum ja da
ist sie mit sich allein hat aber wieder
tonmeister nach prozenten wo die
apparatur bringt die aufnimmt und das
ist nicht nur kalt das ist natürlich
auch ohne supervision ohne aufsicht ohne
hilfe ohne zu spenden jetzt etwas
kritisches über die branche sagen
könnten sollten ich bin auch schon etwas
älter dann würde ich sagen ich finde es
ein bisschen fatal dass die
praktikabilität und das schnell schnell
und das von der werbung her kommende
dass das so überhand nimmt in unserem
beruf ich finde das von übel weil das
die qualität mindert ich muss auch dazu
sagen ich bin ja der einzige das er
vorsichtig sagen darf meiner kategorie
als sprecher in diesem land hier der
weder werbung noch synchron macht weil
ich habe viel geld nicht verdient was
ich gut gebrauchen könnte denn wenn sie
die relationen kennen von gagen für
werbung und für kunst dann fallen in die
ohren ab weil das in zahlen wenn sie es
mal so machen krank war für einen großen
konzern eine werbung zu sprechen eines
sehr bekannten synchronsprecher sind wir
sechsstellig das machen sie in drei vier
stunden dann machen sie 34 fernsehspots
und vielleicht noch vier radiospots und
dann sind sie 100.000 euro reicher und
das ist es macht mich jetzt eben sehr
nachdenklich ja aber so ist sicherlich
dass die amerikaner werden welche
cookies um markt und ich bin ja ein
kleiner nischen mensch also ich und ich
bin sehr froh darum dass ich dort sein
darf aber was ich problematisch finde
ich bin sehr für das populäre mozart war
einer der populärsten komponisten doch
einer der wunderbarsten aber es muss in
eine relation zur qualität stehen und
das geht für manöver von manchmal
verloren wenn es immer zu schnell gehen
muss wenn man eigentlich auch nicht gut
die texte redigiert und so weiter und
das
bemerke ich immer mehr und es gibt die
tendenz das schauspiel das ich nenne das
immer die sauna die bauen sich dann eine
sauna die sitzen dann auf mallorca oder
teneriffa oder wo auch immer und machen
von dort versenden sie dann 50 werbe
spots in der woche oder
ratgeber oder so ich habe jetzt gerade
mal 50 mal 100 tausend das darf ich aber
nicht rechnen
50 mal 100.000 der werbespot geht es
hier um zwei minuten fürs radio das
heißt wer bitte sehr diese zahl da geht
es um vielleicht zehn leute ins land wer
nicht ganz verstehen ganz berühmten
stimuli er sagt auch das ist doch der
konnte ja und das ist ja auch toll weil
weil natürlich dass das hat auch genau
diese diese markt kraft die ich
vollkommen verstehe ich finde man muss
gucken dass das sich nicht überträgt auf
alles weil wir dann natürlich anfangs
sehr büchern auch oft so dass man jetzt
nur noch schaut ja verkauft sich das
denn sie haben ja vorhin das auch
genannt dass sie einerseits durch durch
erntepaar
diesen großen unternehmen das doch mit
erstmal mit zusammengekratzt um geld
gespart wurde und einer menge
enthusiasmus und idealismus und daneben
ein großer großer leistung sie sind auch
mal überrascht worden haben sie vorhin
angedeutet er ist noch immer hören wie
überrascht man sie denn wie kann man sie
denn aus der nische locken mit etwas von
dem sie noch nie gehört hat naja indem
man fragt und sagte gibt es ein buch und
das heißt so und so also dass gegangen
mit einem buch von sullivan ein
amerikanischer thriller autor den nicht
sonst glaube ich nicht unbedingt im
privaten lesen würde da hat man nicht
gefragt ob ich das lesen will neustadt
und der blutrote im himmel statt um
gottes willen was soll das jetzt sein
und das ist ein buch gewesen was mich
überrascht hat und auch begeistert hat
übrigens auch dann die hörer also das
hat man wirklich gemerkt auch in diesem
dieser resonanz weil es ein gut
geschriebener roman ist über eine zeit
die also über den im zeit des faschismus
spielt in italien während der besetzung
der deutschland auch sehr
angelehnt an reale fakten also der mann
hat sehr gut recherchiert geht um reale
figuren wo man wieder staunt über wie
leute die den faschismus mit betrieben
haben nach dem krieg in der
bundesrepublik weiter gelebt haben also
das war eine große sehr schöne
überraschung dass zu machen das herrlich
dass es das gibt dass sie davon
überrascht werden können von solchen
funden es gibt hier noch
autoren die sie sozusagen schon
gewachsen sind wie in der natur die sie
begleiten und die sie begleitet haben
indem sie sie immer wieder eingelesen
haben wir wollen es mal in absteigender
folge darüber sprechen einmal gibt es
den briten philip girl das schon einige
jahre tot leider viel zu früh gestorben
der eine interessante figur in
deutschland der dreißiger erfunden hat
können sie was sagen wann haben sie das
entdeckt war damit zum erstmals
angesprochen und was bringt es ihnen bei
dieser figur von philip k ein detektiv
in den dreißigern sozusagen in
deutschland und mit englischen augen
gesehen was ja immer wichtig ist denn
die die briten sehen uns doch sehr an
das namentlich in der nazizeit wie sind
sie daran gekommen also ich hab
irgendwann vor mindestens 20 jahren
länger her habe ich angefangen mich
aufmerksam geworden auf diese bernie
grund der romane so heißt die figur und
die hat er die ersten drei geschrieben
1989 sind die veröffentlicht worden die
ersten drei dann hat der lange pause
gemacht und auf viele viele andere
bücher geschrieben und dann haben auch
autoren zu ihm gesagt montreal zum
beispiel dieser berühmte historiker du
musst das weiter schreiben weil das so
gut war und dann hat er bis zu seinem
tod insgesamt sind es dann 14 bücher
geworden hat er immer wieder diese figur
zum leben erweckt warum fand ich das gut
ich hatte es beeindruckt erstens der
blick von außen eines englischen autors
also eines schottischen autors aus
edinburgh der offensichtlich keine
deutschen wurzeln hat ich habe erst
gedacht er hat deutsche wurzeln also
körner ist nicht so jedenfalls habe ich
das bis jetzt nicht herausfinden können
der sich so unglaublich genau in der
recherche beschäftigt hat mit dem
faschismus in deutschland mit der
geschichte des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
warum hat mich das beeindruckt es ist
sehr gut geschrieben es ist süffig es
crime es ist auch sechs teilweise es ist
ein richtiger thriller es ist keine
hochliteratur wie man sagt aber es ist
großartige literatur und sie ist
eigentlich ein durchgang durch die
europäische geschichte des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts mit schwerpunkt auf den
faschismus mit schwerpunkt auf
deutschland aber nicht nur auf
deutschland also deutschland bashing
alleine die stadt und das was ich
faszinierend fand ist nochmal in diesen
abgrund zu steigen das fängt an 32 das
letzte buch geht sogar bis 1928 zurück
wo er ganz am ende der reihe nochmals
seine anfänge als kriminalkommissarin
berlin beschreibt
es fällt einem jahr eine reihe ein die
wir jetzt sehr erfolgreich verfilmt
sehen in deutschland die glaube ich den
film sehr viel verdankt er sage ich dazu
nicht
immer kann man das glaube ich nicht nur
ja und es ist eben so dass ich finde im
gegensatz oder vielleicht im verhältnis
zu dieser reihe ohne kritisch zu sein
rückkehr ist nicht nur zeitgeschichte
sondern metaphysik das ist in der tiefe
da wird dann auch sehr viel schopenhauer
goethe man merkt der ist voll mit der
deutschen kultur
und die figur zitiert das auch völlig
unerwartet die man wo man sagt er trinkt
je rund um mag ich kann dem opa und
sondern plötzlich kommt dann so ein
gutes oder es kommt ein ethischer zitat
oder busch und es ist spannend zu
erleben wie ein auto es schafft diese
schrecklichen figuren der zeitgeschichte
heidrich es gibt einen heidrich roman
girls gibt mehr gewiss es gibt fünf
bücher die sich mit erich mielke
beschäftigen dem er immer wieder
begegnet durch die jahrzehnte
beschäftigt sich mit eichmann usw und
das für mich ist das wie eine vesa die
jungen leute wissen nicht mehr was mit
geschichte sie geschäften das ist eine
chance die ganze geschichte sich über
thriller anzueignen offene wahnsinnige
weise und noch an das muss ich sagen ich
habe unglaublich viel recherchiert und
wieder gestaunt alles was da steht ich
habe keine fehler in der recherche
gefunden und erschütternd wie war das
ist weil bei den figuren wieder
auftauchen staunt man denkt das kann
jetzt nicht sein das können sie nicht
gemacht hat den kann es doch nicht in
der bundesrepublik dann gegeben haben
diese nazi doch das
erschütternd aber unglaublich
eindrucksvoll so
wir kommen ja immer wieder da wir haben
doch heute schon einige bücher genannt
die so diese epoche streifen oder sich
mit ihr beschäftigen jetzt weil ich
vorhin sagte wir steigen ab wir steigen
hässlichen ab in die eu literatur er zu
einem finden phänomen das wir nicht
länger anschauen wollen tom clancy den
amerikaner der im jahre 2013 gestorben
ich noch mal gecheckt habe im alter von
66 der eine riesen latte von roman
geschrieben hat und ich habe wirklich
auch mal in der buchhandlung klein sie
in der hand gehabt um zu prüfen was das
für eine prosa ist und sie ist für mich
genauso unlesbar wie der unsägliche dan
brown also nicht wegen der stoff einfach
wegen der puren literarischen
schweinerei der angerichtet wird aber
schweige von natürlich sind solche
figuren wie jack ryan jetzt die wir auch
in zum teil wirklich guten verfilmung
gesehen haben wir wollen jetzt auch
unsere unsere liebhaber von tom klein
sehr abschrecken wir haben schon böses
genug gesagt aber es gibt ein irres
phänomen bei dem vom kleinsten das haben
sie mir mal erzählt sagen sie uns noch
einmal mit der mann ist tot und real
estate als clancy ist eigentlich eine
marke geworden nach seinem tod und marke
heißt es gibt eine spiele die in
kleinensee label haben das hat er für
millionen verkaufter irgendein
spielehersteller und es gibt autoren
cameron heißt einer usw die das
weiterschreiben die nehmen praktisch
dass das material was der kleinen zu
hinterlassen hat und schreiben seitdem
das weiter ich bin überhaupt nicht
hochmütig in dieser beziehung ich lese
jetzt gerade den 28 roman ein dieser
reihe wir wollen jetzt nicht über
stilistisches reden ich will da auch
nicht beckmesser und nix das war mir
nicht aber interessant ist doch dass so
jemand wie klein sie als er noch lebte
seine kontakte hat indes mit
amerikanischen militär die bayern
wirklich patriot für einmal ganz
verhältnisse mit regen befreundet usw
und
clancy hat enorm an geschrieben über
eine attacke mit einem flugzeug drei
jahre vor dem was wird dann erlebt haben
und sie hat eine enorm angeschrieben
über die annexion der krim vier jahre
bevor das dann passiert ist der roman
den wir jetzt schon da geht es um taiwan
und china das heißt ganz vieles was dort
vor gingen in diesen romanen fragen sie
mich bloß nicht wie die einzelnen platz
sind da wäre ich verloren das ist jetzt
auch lange her aber ich muss selber
sagen okay
zumindest inhaltlich
zeitgeschichtlich ist das interessant
und
insofern denke ich warum soll man die
leute vor den kopf stoßen die lust haben
das und es macht auch spaß das zu lesen
das muss man sagen weil da kann man
natürlich sachen machen die man sonst
nicht macht da gibt es ganz viele
military tag ich kenne alle
waffensysteme ich habe mir alle pistolen
und maschinenpistolen also ich frag mich
schon ob die mich irgendwie suchen weil
ich im internet dann mal gucken wie
sieht denn die smith wesson
hielt und so aus weil ich auch wenn ich
so einen roman vorlesen oder vielleicht
dann sogar noch mehr muss ich wissen
worum geht es da wie sieht dieser
flugzeugträger aus in was für einem
flugzeug sitzen die was ist das für eine
waffe so das ist vielleicht mehr sein so
ein steckenpferd da geht es um die
anständigkeit wenn man einen solchen
roman an dem zu lesen dann liest man den
so gut vor wie es geht und darum mache
ich das und ich finde es auch sehr
lustig wie die leute reagieren es gibt
schon auch leute die sagen na ja früher
früher war der kleine sich selber das
war viel besser ich meine jagd auf roter
oktober zum beispiel verfilmt mit sean
connery näher als berühmter filme es
gibt ein buch ein politisch völlig
unkorrekt das buch da geht es um einen
rachefeldzug in einem drogenmilieu der
ist
sehr hart und da denkt man oft an der
flicks sehen heute also
aber es ist natürlich interessant was
sie sagen jeder einzelne von uns und ich
würde wirklich sagen jeder einzelne von
uns hat ein verhältnis zuschauer
literatur auf eine bestimmte weise sehr
persönliche weise ich selber habe im
laufe der jahre und jahrzehnte gemerkt
dass ich so wellen hatten sich bestimmte
sachen lesen konnte taxi weggelegt und
10 15 20 jahren nicht lesen können vor
zwei jahren bekam ich wieder
merkwürdigerweise dann in den usa kurz
vor der pandemie eine welle mit crime
fiction -arie wo ich das neu würdigen
konnte wo ich 15 jahre vorher oder zehn
jahre wäre ja gar nicht mehr drin war
und sagte es ist es ist mir zuviel ist
zuviel stopfen und das was hier gerade
angedeutet haben ist ja auch diese
stoffe bereit die kann sie ihn haben
beim lesen mal denn sie findet aber auch
in unserem leben statt und gerade wenn
sie jetzt sagen ein zeitbezug hilft dann
dann können wir das damit an verändern
muss dazu sagen natürlich dass ich
manchmal sehr traurig bin das sehr gute
kriminalroman serien oder crime deutsche
nicht produziert werden michael tippten
zb erinnert der wunderbarsten und auch
so klug eigentlich wenn ein verlag da
wäre dann müsste ich sagen ist eine
tolle idee er schreibt 14 glaube ich
romane oder 15 die immer in einer
anderen die technische region spielen
hat es doch für den tourismus touch aber
der mann ist halt 2006 leider gestorben
und wir leben heute in diesem diktum es
muss alles aktuell und sofort und so als
sein buch was wir wochen nicht verkauft
ist schon tot das finde ich sehr
problematisch ist jedoch dass also ich
würde auch hinzufügen dass bei tippt in
den ich sehr gern gelesen habe bin ich
wirklich auch in meiner kriminal der
neuen welle noch mal wieder gelesen habe
gerade die ersten ja das zweite fand ich
schwach das erste und dritte fand ich
toll von der erste orient sense reihe
und aber dieses ältere italien dazu
sehen was geht noch mal
ja aber auch das auch politisch hohe
ausland sehr dass so was wie heiß mit
oder so ich meine wahl chandler und so
also man muss sagen da ist schon alt und
viele leute das muss ich noch loswerden
viele leute vergleichen jacke mit
chandler und zwar positiv negativ und
ich finde dass das sehr wahr ist also
näher hat den sender auch sehr verehrt
man merkt das auch aber ich finde hat es
auf einem sehr hohen niveau auch
geschafft erst muss ich aber auch weil
sie jetzt in ihren lieblingen gekommen
jetzt komme ich mit einem meiner nämlich
mit ross macdonald
einfach deswegen weil er eigentlich der
chandler erbe ist im sinne dieses typus
des
einsamen
wild und dann hat er dieses kalifornien
und da hat mir eingeleuchtet wollen wir
mal ganz kurz noch bevor wir uns
verabschieden ganz kurz über die
herrlichsten klappen
es gab diesen satz den ich nie vergessen
werde dabei war auf den alten grünen
penguin heißt jetzt ja ja wir stehen ist
es heißt es schreibt
über figuren wie eine spinne überfliegen
schreiben würde sache okay das war nicht
einfach klasse ja dann halt die
spielerinnen taste und das hat mich
überzeugt aber auch das andere war das
tatsächlich klappt einen text schreiben
übrigens wir sind was mir einen
vielleicht projekt was ich auch machen
durfte vorjahr ich habe den grünen
heinrich vorgelesen
und da gibt es die wunderbare fliegen
stelle im park wenn sie sich erinnern wo
genau der sitzt und die beobachtet was
die spinne mit der fliege
tolle ideen die haben die späte fassung
gelesen wir haben die später fällt ja
nein dazu zu keller kommen wir dann weil
er anders war als ich lade sie noch mal
an aber diese sachen mit den klappentext
natürlich teil unserer kultur und
unseres bücher besitzen und zu büchern
gehen ich würde ganz gerne als
rausschmeißer einfach nur zitieren eine
witzigkeit die ich im zusammenhang mit
tom clancy gefunden habe im wall street
journal vor sechs jahren war da ein
artikel erschienen der seite wollen wir
nicht mal zu ende denken wenn tom clancy
eine roman manufaktur aufgemacht eine
industrie die mit dem label tom clancy
arbeitet können wir dann nicht auch
folgendes machen die haben das
vorgeschlagen in ihrem artikel
best selling a 4 oder dostojewski eine
brüder karamasow geschichte ja bei so
hoher kran ja also einfach mal diese
sachen oder auch von von jane ost von
jane austen ist es ja geschehen weil den
osten sind stoffe weiter geschrieben
worden
also das ist so ein bisschen diese idee
dass man sozusagen die die die figuren
als marke nimmt und vorführt und so
erleben wir es heute auch in der 6 wir
müssen glaube ich los machen es war mir
ein riesen vergnügen frank lammert ich
werde spaß gemacht ich werde sie weiter
hören wie ein wahnsinniger und
irgendwann hören wir uns wieder vielen
dank sehr gerne vielen dank
[Musik]
heute gibt es auch wieder ein neues
literatur rätsel von tilman spreckelsen
der wie stets pointiert die geschichte
eines bekannten buches erzählt nämlich
aus der sicht einer nebenfigur ich lese
ihnen das jetzt vor liebe hörerinnen
liebe hörer und wenn sie zu wissen
glauben wie figur und werk heißen dann
machen sie doch gerne mit
da zogen sie hin mein patenonkel und
mein liebster mein onkel der professor
mit riesigen schritten mein liebster
trampelte mit im gepäck hinterher am
abend zuvor war er noch zu mir hinaus
nach altona gekommen mein liebster hatte
mir erzählt wie der professor das papier
mit den runen in dem alten burg gefunden
und entschlüsselt hat und wir nun
gezwungen sei mit ihm zu einer reise
aufzubrechen die vor ihnen noch kein
mensch unternommen hätte mit ausnahme
des wohnen schreibers natürlich ich
fürchte fast mein liebster wollte von
mir hören dass ich es lieber sähe wenn
er hier geblieben wäre aber wie hätte
ich ihm dazu raten können nach allem was
zwischen uns war nach all den gesteinen
die wir miteinander untersucht haben all
den zarten berührungen der geschliffenen
flächen und den schönen stunden mit den
koryphäen der mineralogie nein sagte ich
ihm du musst gehen erst in den norden
dann in die tiefe und wenn du zurück
bist dann dann nun ja
und so ist es dann auch gekommen
haben sie ahnung wer da spricht und aus
welchem buch er oder sie erzählt dann
schicken sie uns ihre lösung bitte bis
zum 6 dezember 2021 an unsere e mail
adresse bücher - podcast faz.de bücher
natürlich mit
unter den richtigen einsendungen
verlosen wir diesmal die nacht des
doktor herzfeld und schnee eine art
doppel roman von georg hermann hermann
jahrgang 1971 war ein flaneur und
wehmütiger chronist des jüdisch
bürgerlichen lebens in der metropole
berlin vor und nach dem ersten weltkrieg
das buch kommt wie bei uns üblich aus
der anderen bibliothek ist also
garantiert schön anzuschauen und schön
an zu fassen und wie immer vielen dank
an den verlag auf unserer webseite
www.faz.net bücher - podcast bücher mit
finden sie die teilnahmebedingungen und
die adresse für die lösung des rätsels
der rechtsweg ist natürlich
ausgeschlossen
vielen dank dass sie wieder dabei waren
und bis bald
[Applaus]